readings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by policy genius in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers so you
can get the right amount of coverage at
the best possible price that's policy
genius.com the church is also brought to
you by on it you [ __ ] watch my
Twitter you see I refueled with some
alpha brain and some shroom tech I'm
ready a [ __ ] rock baby it's gonna be
a tremendous fall but hey go to Anna
calm right now look at the great
supplements after off some shrimp tech
sports room tech immune the coconut
almond choco bars to the seven grams of
protein each [ __ ] eat them on the run
no drama
on it has it all go to Anna calm right
now press in church BAM and get 10% off
your first order delivered right to your
[ __ ] crib like a doctor you
understand me and alpha brain is backed
100% money-back guarantee and they don't
even want the [ __ ] product back else
does that nobody so go to honor calm
right now Lee kick this [ __ ]
meal miss James hello a pleasure to have
you here thank you for having me
absolutely a world renowned violinist
when there's any [ __ ] podcast and
good looks to boot
cuz you those violinists too kind of
[ __ ] up big guys they're all warp
nishapur
you got all the goods what's happened oh
I'm just been gigging in LA just got
back from touring with Burt Bacharach oh
no no you have a resume exactly good for
that later are you originally from
Southern California no I was born in
England actually England
and Huck where's the accent I went away
when I moved to us when I was really
young how old were you when you moved to
the US um pretty young about a year old
okay and where'd you relocate
Philadelphia no [ __ ]
stayed in Philly for a while for a while
and then my dad he's a doctor and he got
a job in Oklahoma we moved there when
did you pick up the violin when I was
four it's funny because I got interested
in your videos and awesome
started talking on toilet speaking on
Twitter and my daughter went to
kindergarten last year and they signed
her up she picked the violin oh that's
great so they're like little cardboard
violin
yeah that's awesome and she loved it you
know I was going to have you over to
come over one day and eat with us and
totally violin from blow her [ __ ]
mind
but at the recital the violin teacher
got on my last nerve right because you
know you went there like it's a [ __ ]
dirty recital right so parents got to
leave you know like people got to move
in this town by 10 8:30 in the morning
3:00 in the morning you know I'm all in
I go to bed early I get up and she puts
on a pretty dress and she's waiting to
[ __ ] play the violin with any other
savages and the violin teachers like
well hold on first me and my husband
have to do a duet from my new album I
mean you know so she used the kids to
promote her own [ __ ] yeah and it was
the worst music in the world look like a
[ __ ] cat that she's just drugged and
she was like a bomb and they're up there
in the morning and ever been looking at
each other so [ __ ] uncomfortable we
came in to see our kids playing this
dirty [ __ ]
is taking up that time and the kids
didn't like four minutes and that was it
in the car that man she said I don't
like her no more she goes she's a hog
she lured us down there to get an
audience
[ __ ] 20-minute [ __ ] Jam at 8:30
the more like I know reef Rumi I'm
trying to be a decent man
at least you fill me up with some reefer
if you gotta let me know these [ __ ]
ladies are playing so she's signing up
for it this year
I think that was will true somatically
but so you pick with the violin at four
yeah when did you become serious about
it I think I've always been serious
about it I I was actually watching I
remember watching Sesame Street and
seeing Itzhak Perlman on the episode and
saying mommy I want to do that and I
just walked around the house and
pretended I was playing
my parents were like hmm we should get
her one of those so and I'm I never my
parents never had to make me practice I
always wanted to play so did you what we
doing at 12 13 12 13 I was playing in a
college Orchestra in Oklahoma and I was
part of a touring group called the
Ottawa Suzuki strings and we went all
over the world and we were ambassadors
for the US and we played different
schools you know for other kids kind of
like a sister school program thing and
um it was a lot of fun I got to travel
and I think that's where I got the
travel bug like my first tour was when I
was 11 I was like alright this is it I'm
done go to the road that's all with you
no actually they sent you away like what
a Michael Jackson just take the with you
[ __ ] it don't worry about nothing it's
funny now because my mom she said to me
the other day she was like I don't know
what I was thinking I let my
eleven-year-old go to England by herself
how long were you away from um like a
month on tour and then I have relatives
there so then how was your high school
high school I actually didn't go to
conventional school I was part of a
educational co-op and it was kind of set
up like a college where you pick your
classes and you go to school only on the
dates that you have classes and then you
have a tutor that you can contact and
and you it's pretty you have to be
pretty self-sufficient but you didn't go
to like a musical high school no they
didn't they didn't really have one where
I was [ __ ] yeah so that's why I was in
the college orchestra and then would you
go to college I went to Azusa Pacific
out here okay and that's where you told
your [ __ ] up yeah it means a lot of
contacts yeah well you're doing that
high school to focus on music yes I was
in because I was doing college music
classes so I would do my high school you
know math and science and all that stuff
and then the college music classes were
on other days but I actually moved to
California when I was
fifteen and a half and was a nanny for
my violin teacher so I finished high
school out here
no you one thing I dig about you is that
you just don't play classical stuff like
you johner is hip-hop everyone you have
a really good jazz bass like I was
looking at some of your videos like you
do jazz you know I read something about
you you like hip-hop yeah it's so weird
like a guy like me an Archon art reason
why I have you on the show today's to
prove to people that artists appreciate
each other and we have prenup
who would have think over the thing that
yeah yeah you were attractive and I
looked at you watch you play the violin
but then the more I watch I fell in love
with you plan I'm like I wonder what her
[ __ ] path was like you know as a
comic you know her path is dark [ __ ]
ballrooms and bars and people throwing
[ __ ] is hitting people in the head with
microphones and [ __ ] what was it like
for you yeah for me the journey I mean I
if my mom listens to this mom I snuck
out of the house and played with bands
when I was 13 I used to climb out the
window and I played with this college
band and they would sneak me into the
club in the bass drum case because I was
you know I couldn't walk through the
front door so I would I would curl up in
a ball in the bass drum case and they'd
carry me in and I'd play with the band
and then they'd kick me out of bar so I
I always you know I always have loved
music from every genre so any chance I
got I was jamming with anyone anyone who
wanted to play and I used to practice on
my front porch you know just to
entertain my neighbors so when I was a
kid what's-his-name came out what the
devil came out of Georgia oh yeah Daniel
who what the violin in our like we
respected it as
13 euros we don't like this whoa he's
[ __ ] just a devil went down to
georgia and all this [ __ ] you know today
we don't have that nobody has introduced
like to me I learned everything early on
you know I want yeah I grew up in
Manhattan so our grammar schools would
take us to like Lincoln Center to watch
those dudes play all that [ __ ] and we
would sit there like what the [ __ ] are
we watching but after a while even
though knucklehead like me saw that
there was a certain type of beauty you
know whenever I go to Detroit I get in
the car and I go to the outside of the
troit this is one bar I can't remember
the name of it now Monday nights the
[ __ ] Blues just you know six guys I
know in Burbank here on Monday nights
they get together at some bar a friend
of mine Lonnie citron Oh a bunch he's
like [ __ ] the guy from ZZ Top showed
up last Monday yeah I love all that [ __ ]
yeah who I live for you know I love for
just people popping in and you know you
popping in with [ __ ] slash you know
like how would that be yeah and when did
you go professional um well I started I
joined the Union when I was 14 what you
do so it was a FM okay
yeah American Federation of musicians
because I was playing I was a sub for um
the Oklahoma symphonia and so I was in
Tulsa Philharmonic and I was I was
playing with them so I guess that was
you know I thought oh I'm professional
now you know I'm getting paid so there
we go
you know um the youngest person in the
orchestra yeah that's pretty and so it
is amazing and it's not amazing it's
it's a lot of pressure when you're
really young and you're around all these
yeah he goes big egos yeah my wife
worked at the LA Phil oh cool she did
the accounting for the Hollywood Bowl
and stuff so you know I would always
hear the stories of a [ __ ] dude with
the stick what's his name the conductor
came back the [ __ ] whole thing in the
egos and yeah and you could tell that
it's from an ego based
Society type of sort so yeah I can't
even imagine how some of the men looked
at you or some of the women looked at
you yeah it's it's tough because you
know it takes so long to get to that
point where you are in an orchestra
that's as good as Hollywood Bowl you
know you have to work so hard for your
whole life and beat out so many people
you know you can have if there's a chair
open in LA Phil you can have a thousand
people trying to get one chair and
there's a joke that every people say
that um you know in order to get into LA
Phil somebody has to die because what
nobody's gonna give up their seat in LA
Phil or any big Philharmonic like that
so they literally will have that chair
until they die with someone like you be
attracted to that notion of working for
the LA I felt I was I mean it would be
an honor to play in LA Phil it's I think
I used to want to be just that classical
player but as I got older and I really
love traveling and playing just
different kinds of music you know just
like playing playing with Burt and then
going to a bar and playing the Blues and
then playing Dvorak American string
quartet you know I like the variety of
it and I like I like being in smaller
groups I think although there's
absolutely nothing that compares with
like playing Beethoven's ninth with a
symphony it being in the middle of
everyone creating that that sound of
that feeling oh that's beautiful there's
nothing like it
now the LA Phil do they play year-round
they have a season so it's LA Phil is I
believe October through June okay and
then it it overlaps a little bit with
Hollywood Bowl a lot of the LA Phil
people also play on Hollywood Bowl but
yeah they they take the summer off
pretty much now what were your twenties
why
doing this stuff I mean lots of lots of
different bands you know I mean I was
looking at names some I recognized yeah
I did but I seem like everyone champagne
king yeah like what did you do for her
Oh so that's a funny story actually yeah
we did oh you did yes I got this gig um
and you know I'm freelance
so a lot of people you they'll call you
and Hank be like hey we're so we're
doing this benefit or this party can you
are you available and like most times
you know sometimes you've never played
with the pan before and they just give
you charts and you go this one was a
benefit for like Children's Hospital in
San Diego and it was a 70s themed
benefit and they said oh we're gonna
play the music of Evelyn champagne King
Gloria Gaynor you know and I need a ward
and then I should thinking it was a
cover gig I show up and we're on
costumes and super fun and then the real
artist didn't I had no idea it was the
craziest thing and I'm like how did you
do ring my bell we did well we had it
was a huge band we had keys and drums
and and we had a synth strings but I was
the only actual real violinist on the
gig and so thinking before oh it's a
cover gig you know they gave me the
charts but then once the real artist
walked in I was like oh my god I have to
go practice right now but they were
super nice everyone was really gracious
I think Chaka Khan was there too yeah
that's crazy
yeah and so you know accompanied them by
with all those disco heads yeah let's
give it a tremendous different sound oh
it does I mean disco music is built on
the strings disco strings are amazing so
it's crazy yeah that I was watching say
that while I was on I was getting ready
to go to the comedy store and I caught
like the last dirty minute you're a bum
you're never gonna be somebody but [ __ ]
you like to dance he goes down there and
you know he's doing that oh [ __ ]
thing I still remember walking to the
movie theater to see that walking home
going holy [ __ ] yeah that's crazy I
gotta start wearing shoes but now how
did you hook up with Burt Bacharach and
Paul Anka who was first
Bert was first Bert was how old was Bert
Becky is 91 god bless that [ __ ]
yeah he's amazing and how old is Paul
Anka he just turned 78 how good does he
look oh my god he looks amazing know
what's really crazy about what was about
to discuss is that pretty much I got to
assume that maybe 30% of the people who
listened to this podcast because of
their age yeah not because of any do not
know who Bert back Burt Bacharach and
Paul Anka who did you make contact with
first I was actually contacted by met I
went to a show of birds and I met his
music director and he introduced me to
him and you know just introduced me to
the band just hanging out I was doing a
recording project for the music director
and then I went to a couple more shows
and then I got a call and it was Bert
and he said hey so I'm down at the
studio on Sunset and I have this violin
part you know can you come down and
listen to it it was like what okay sure
so I went down to the studio and
listened to the violin part it was off
the album who are these people I believe
is the name of the album it was a it was
a instrumental wanted Grammy for Best
instrumental but I had never heard it
before and he played it for me
and I was like wow that's a beautiful
violin solo of course and he said yes so
you're free in October you want to do
Vegas and that was it and
for people who don't know I mean Burke
bank records won't Academy Awards
oh yeah Grammys I mean he just his
resume you know this is 60 years in the
business maybe 70 yes yes maybe 70 if
he's 91 well assume he's like you he's
been doing this since he was 15 or
[ __ ] 12 or something yeah and that's
just Jay's written music for [ __ ]
everywhere everyone everybody
yeah he's written for over a thousand
[ __ ] and musicians over a thousand
and have trusted him
Burt Bacharach that's how strong he is
yeah well then how did you meet Paul
Anka how long we working for Burt before
you met Paul
so I've I've been in Burt's van for 16
years
yeah saying that out loud missing so
long oh my gosh [ __ ] yeah 16 years
Sebold birth to 16 I walked into the
equation I have been in pause band for
six and a half years now so I just got a
call his music director I was
recommended to him and they were doing
some kind of beta testing for a hologram
and he needed another violinist so he
said hey can you come you know and we
basically played my way for two days
straight in a pit while they like beta
tested this hologram I never even saw it
I think it was a Frank Sinatra hologram
and then so I did that and only played
one song but the fan was so cool
everybody in the group was great and
then like a couple days later they were
like uh you want to go to Singapore for
New Year's and then I was it you know be
you are you're in Bert's band for sixty
ten years 16 years ten years yes at the
time and now Paul Anka's calling you up
yeah describe to the audience who the
[ __ ] or anchors Paul Anka is one of the
earliest
real pop stars 14:14 yeah in Canada yeah
he he started writing I think when he
was 12 he wrote Diana and he is one of
the most driven and dedicated people you
will never find anyone that works harder
than either of my bosses but he you know
Paul he knew what he wanted and he had
the package he put it together he
understood really early on what it was
to appeal to your audience he he had a
good read for that and he still does he
knows exactly how to work the audience
and he started touring with a group like
Annette Funicello and they would pile on
these buses and go all over the country
and you know go to these radio shows
that they used to do back then and then
everybody would you know Buddy Holly was
on it and they would sing a couple songs
and then get them bus and go to the next
one and you know work their way around
the country so you know he was he was
definitely I would say comparing now we
don't really have any know any pop stars
like that maybe Justin Timberlake would
be the the closest you know that level
of dedication and talent to the craft
what was his connection to Frank he
wrote something Frank yeah something big
for Frank he wrote a couple things for
Frank
he wrote well he wrote the lyrics to my
way you know that little song just a
little ditty yeah um he wrote the lyrics
to my way and he also wrote another hit
for Frank let me try again when he came
back he left show business for a while
and then he came back and he premiered
it at Madison Square Garden but he was
working with I mean he was super young
he was probably like 21 when he started
working with the Rat Pack in in Vegas so
he wrote for Sammy Davis jr.
he's like.he I read different books I
think it was a Dean Martin book I read
when I was locked up he was like the
type of guy I deem described him like he
would say little things to you that
would change everything
mm-hmm dog don't wear now one shiny
shoes or say this at the end of this
song right he just knew how to tweak
things to make him [ __ ] perfect like
everybody took his advice from Frank
to Michael Jackson oh yeah [ __ ]
everybody was at Paul Anka like a Paul
Anka had a hook and everybody in some
way or another if you knew anything
about music
you just wanted him to just watch you
one time and go maybe you should do this
yeah maybe you should look this way
instead of that one you're like what and
also you're like oh my god like that's
the impression I get of Paul helped
everybody yeah he is very observant like
something each other wedding was it
someone just somebody like a [ __ ]
crazy guy was quoting Paul Anka I was
like this is crazy
like could Jimmy pay I don't know who it
was some rock star maybe Elvis yeah
Elvis Elvis yeah yeah
it's crazy so is he a songwriter or what
he will pee pee a week um PA man um PA
was he's a songwriter he's a performer
he is he's everything he does everything
he could say he can sing his voice now
is so it's amazing it's really amazing
you guys got to come to the show so for
the last 16 years you know they would
just had a thing about Fredo on last
week I'm afraid I'll call Corvo yeah but
regardless of this I don't know if you
know this about the guy who played for
you though he did five movies everything
he played in one of the Kami award oh
wow
the hunter Godfather to Godfather one
well like all five of his movies if you
look him up well they play Fredo
that dude you know they did a
documentary on him Dog Day Afternoon oh
yeah he played those or whatever when he
asked him would we want to go we steal
the bank when we robbed a bank they did
a documentary on him you know everything
he touched turned to [ __ ] gold he did
five movies that were [ __ ] like
Academy Award winners - some [ __ ] you
know so wait an arrow was his body yeah
Chino was his body and then was John
Cazale John Cazale let's see if I can
find out we did here oh my god
he did a couple of TV things but then
the Godfather the conversation Godfather
Part two Dog Day Afternoon and the
hunter Wow he won five my point is how
is it how does it feel to be around two
greats like the education you're getting
oh it's amazing
remember Sonny and his [ __ ] Bronx
Tale he's like you're getting a student
education and you're getting a book
education yeah you are getting an
education that most people can't even
fat yeah it's and I'm very glad that I
realized that early right away you know
sometimes you get a gig and you're like
oh this is cool and and it's more than
cool you know playing for these guys
it's more than cool I've learned so much
about not just music but about how to be
how to act on stage how to present
yourself you know what how to work an
audience you know working a crowd is an
art I mean you know you do it all the
time
and it's it's an art and sometimes you
get an audience that they just we call
we call them the two rich to clap you
know and you know they'll do a benefit
or something and they're just like
sitting there and drinking their wine
and you hear the you know the forks
clinking on the plates
they're like it's so great you know we
pay we had the Beach Boys here last week
this is so cool and you know they don't
really they pay for these big performers
to come in but it's they do it so often
it's like nothing and but Paul Anka can
take that audience and have them on
their feet in three minutes
how does he do it he he he works this
magic he runs through the crowd he
involves them in he'll you know say
start singing stay with me and then put
the mic to somebody's mouth and they'll
be like Diana so there it's interactive
you know that all of the whole show is
meticulously put together you know the
energy levels at certain places and and
he's off the cuff like he's pretty funny
so people will yell things you know lady
the other day she was like I love you
Paul he's like I'll see you backstage
after the show No so he I think people
when they come to the Anka show they
feel like they're in their own living
room sometimes they heckle a little too
much I think it really undo it but Mike
in Vegas yeah okay we've had some we did
a show in actually it was in Santiago
Chile and it was in this giant arena and
he hadn't been to South America and
quite some time and packed and he runs
through the audience at the beginning of
the show and we underestimated how
excited this audience like hey there
it's only this story after the show
there was this woman who was so excited
in front of him and you know the general
age of the people who know who Paul Anka
is but you know she was so excited she
was standing in front of him and she
started to say something and her teeth
fell out right in front of PA and he was
just standing there he's like I didn't
know what to do
there was just teeth on the floor I'm
not gonna pick him up what's the average
age of our shot it 50 to 70 yeah I would
say 50 to 70 with Bert it's kind of it
very very it very also varies country to
country you know with Burt he's huge
everywhere and so if Anka but it's I
think that in England and the UK
especially like there's such an
incredible fan base for Burt there I
mean we just got back from there and the
audience sings louder than we play you
know but it varies there's kids that
that love Anka and they send me
Instagram videos of them singing
everybody yeah he wrote that both he
sang that yeah what do you think that
was like the big how I got to the way I
had to be I think that with him in the
show now though you yeah you sing - yeah
oh wow so yeah because you still do that
live we aren't doing well right now
we're doing Anka thing Sinatra um so
that's a little bit different than our
regular show but in the regular show we
do it and if somebody yells out having
my baby so he'll do a little bit of it
you know notion sometimes the audience
will say having my baby he'll be like I
hope not
you know it's so weird how I won't point
in comedy for you to get stronger as a
comic hmm oh yeah isn't a violinist or
as a performer let's use the word
performer
yeah you have to watch I reason like I
thought people all the time when I when
I'm on stage in the back of my mind it's
Breyer it's Robert Plant mm-hmm
I love his body movements on stage he
yeah he underlined his words with his
body yeah on stage when you watch his
poor Robert Plant he underlines his
words with his body
Rod Stewart I love live you know Mick
Jagger you know how amazing ah
there's certain people that you have to
watch you know when I watch you you did
a video the other day
I love Elton John like a tribute oh yeah
it was just all these people moving and
you know I watch all that that's what
makes a performer yeah I'm a comedian
but that means I could go onstage and
just tell jokes that's gonna take me so
far I'm right the next part the next
phase that is becoming a performer yeah
I mean how to use your body to control
the audience yeah that goes into it you
know I love watching Lennox get it alive
from open 1977 how that little chubby
dude controls the audience body all this
goes I tell people all this oh I'm BB
King live in Africa Jesus he's there
yeah like he's saying the words and he's
there like he's telling this [ __ ] it's
over what's that some of these things
they're really they're really good BB
King Oh watch it live from Africa in
front of him is that woman
yes Darla like it's [ __ ] over then he
hits the guitar oh yeah [ __ ] it's the
guitar again that's to become a good
performer you have to study all those
guys you know and even like an actor
dress is nice mm-hmm you know let me
comes on it's like he's on rollerskates
but you don't see him right it's really
smooth
yeah he's smooth so when I watch the
hand come way look at Sinatra yeah even
so notch at the end with the twisted wig
and the [ __ ] the teleprompter he was
still [ __ ] up the words so Natsu is
such a Sinatra at the end they had a
teleprompter and he'd be singing my way
like let's do fly me to the moon with my
way you said that because um we had
Bruce Buffer in here and he's not a
musician he's the voice of the UFC and
he he did his announcing and I was
sitting next to him in it like it
honestly felt like like a bomb went off
like I could like just the energy that
came off of him so you were saying like
the energy like with a with it like a UH
orchestra like do you feel that when
you're in when you in the middle
telling vibrating it was kind of crazy
yeah you feel it and your serve at
completely surrounded by it you know and
it's it's really special and that I
think that's the mark of any really good
performer when they're in the moment
like you can the energy is palpable you
know when you're really going for it and
drawing the audience and the audience
also gives you energy audience you know
it's you it's a two-way street you can't
if you have a dead audience that won't
react to anything then it drains you
because you're working and you're trying
to drag it out let them drag it out of
them and yeah but when you have that
audience that just is really excited to
be there and you know what it knows the
songs and they sing along I can't what I
would love one thing that I would love
on my bucket list is to have the
experience that Burt had when we were in
England and the audience was singing
along just the look on his face the joy
knowing that not expecting anything when
you walk out onto the stage but then
realizing that you have impacted all of
these people's lives like that person
over there got married to your song that
person over there named their baby after
your song and then having everyone sing
along and that exchange of energy that
was probably one of the most incredible
moments you know I was a level that you
want to get there that's the I would
just I would love to have one song I'm
not saying I have to write a thousand
songs because you know I'm not Burt
Bacharach but I would love to have one
song and just have that experience I
think that would be incredible that they
would sing that song yeah yeah with you
yeah I I would I would hate to do it as
a comment that means you're not right
material all right but as a yeah like
you know when you go see stairway to
heaven the second anthem yeah when you
that would be amazing to have
an anthem in your career like yeah
football how many thought after missus
boy oh my god Christ so many she's
running I'm trying to think of somebody
I like I read a bunch of books and I was
locked up and I kept hearing his name
and I knew him it's like it's like you
know when I was growing up there was
this weird vibe from 72-73 music was we
had great music yeah there was this
undercurrent that is Leo Sayer nobody
else am and I don't wanna go
you had the captain tenneal you had that
genre and that's about the time I think
Paul came out with having my baby maybe
73 yeah I think it was and that's what I
know about Paul I can I was young kid
but having my baby [ __ ] pretty cool I
can't you know like it was just assumed
that that caught on and now I like you
know I read that he'll Michael Jack
there was somebody else he worked with
that blew my [ __ ] mind
he's worked for Buble he helped start
Michael bublé's career Michael Buble
there was somebody out like he's just
little but we were getting back to Burt
Bacharach that you were saying people
saying this songs it's 60 70 years of
experience yeah you can't take that away
no it's it you can't take that away from
people
no you can't that's why now like at the
18 year mark of comedy I had doubts I
still have doubts but now I'm gonna join
Tae Kwan I have doubts now yeah I go
Joey you've been doing this get your
[ __ ] ass together get down to the
comedy store and get on stage you
[ __ ] tired your [ __ ] [ __ ] cuz I
don't have material well 20 years you
don't have [ __ ] material you don't
have nothing to say at the 28 years get
that shower wash your [ __ ]
and get that car and get on the world
Canyon you I have to say that to myself
sometimes yeah but that experience you
can't take away I'm very proud yeah but
I slept on Graham buses because now I
see it right I see it when I'm on stage
I see it when I turn and when I do
certain things at all but it's doing
this in Charlotte that man
a bag of dicks around that black
audience you know it all comes back so
that's something day you're having a
shortcut you're in a beautiful position
you're in a beautiful position to have
that hit if you really think about it
because you have all the tools around
you yeah you have the right guidance you
could go to PA and go PA I'm thinking of
a song I want to write you know yeah
having a baby's daddy daddy
but you hate me have a baby's daddy you
know and you could yeah support so yeah
if this was the time for you to do what
a great thing like just to write a song
and give it to somebody like one of the
greatest stories I ever heard was that
Oh John call John Lennon I said what the
[ __ ]
you wrote Fame for David Bowie he goes
yeah what's the problem he goes what the
what am i chose give me a couple days
[ __ ] back with Benny and the Jets well
that's me
is better than having your own it like
hold on give me a couple days yeah Benny
in the [ __ ] Jets for you get the [ __ ]
out of his [ __ ] [ __ ] classes on and
[ __ ] boy smack it before I have Yoko
karate champion but I love that that's a
big honor to have your Pierre at that
level write a song for you specifically
for you thinking of you like this it's
not it's not just a song that's gonna be
like shopped around and then go to you
know maybe this country artists will
cover it at some point you know it's a
song that was written specifically for
him and that's it that's a huge that's a
huge honor give me one minute and now
for a word from my sponsor the church
what's happening now is sponsored by
policy genius these days a lot of jobs
well for some pretty nice perks snacks
fifteen flavors of soda water even life
insurance but while it's nice to have
those perks you can't feed your family
with
water and trail mix uncle Joey's here to
tell you neither is your workplace life
insurance that's why this policy genius
comes in policy genius is the easy way
to shop for insurance online just going
to policy genius.com
in minutes you can compare quotes on the
top insurers see you can get the right
amount of coverage at the best possible
price so remember workplace life
insurance policies are like workplace
next better than nothing but not quite
enough head to policy genius.com today
and find out how to supplement your
workplace life insurance and better
protect your family policy genius get
your insurance today at policy
genius.com and tell'em uncle Joey sent
you sorry about that let's get this
party started
well I was a she was like I can't even
imagine being it would be like being
around John Mulaney and Dave Chappelle
either or week we had been for John
Mulaney and look at that perspective of
it yeah and the other week I'm opening
up it had to be somebody was even longer
in the game and Dave Chappelle liked the
game Dahmer era for years you know how
to Philly just it's not even it's
looking how they walk looking how they
talk you know how they go on stage
Wow they shine their shoes before they
go on stage it's that interesting won't
make it doesn't work out yeah he goes on
stage you know what the ritual the
ritual you learn the rituals of
different people and then you compare me
you come up with your own ritual you
know your eyes must be you know you
could tell stories that nobody's even
comprehend see oh yeah
it's it's something that you learn just
by being around them but you you really
do have to pay attention you know you
can't get all swept up in the oh it's
cool to be on tour now you know what
sometimes you learn the MA
when you're you're sitting next to
someone at dinner and they're talking
about okay well you know I think what do
you think about this part of the show
should we do should we tweak it for this
what's this audience like and and the
questions that they asked of the band
you know to find out how we think as
well because I think that as a unit you
know we all have played together for six
and a half years now in ankus band and
we don't really we rehearse sometimes
you know we'll have a soundcheck but we
don't really rehearse we don't have to
you know rehearse during the week like
there's no Wednesday night somewhere no
oh there have it I think twice maybe you
know but everybody's Pro everybody knows
the music and but PA is always trying to
make the show better even when you're
like this show couldn't be better than
this
how are you gonna make it better than
this he's always trying to make it
better
we missed each other and Boston yeah
Connecticut and I was yeah I couldn't
get out early enough you couldn't get
out early make each other's show yeah
but when you showed me the place like I
was blown the [ __ ] away oh yeah I'm like
actors someone some numbers was that
Acco that was that was the Mohegan Sun
right that was Mohegan that was anchor
go don't [ __ ] kill him
oh yeah how much this anchor travel
during the week pa how during the year
how many weeks does he do um we do like
see we do like oh I think it a ver just
out to about a week a month maybe two
week two weeks a month throughout the
year it depends it changes we used to
tour a little bit more than we do now um
like we did a month in Europe we're
gonna do probably do a month in
Australia and New Zealand in in the
spring and we've got mostly its weekend
dates for now so when you go out with
mr. back Rach how many nights do you do
in a week
we usually do we don't do more than two
in a row okay yeah no your body can't
take yeah and it and it's you know we
also travel with three singers so it's
and it's pretty taxing it's a the show
is difficult for the for everyone
it doesn't sound difficult because we
make it sound easy but I know the
singers there's a lot of pressure you
you know these songs are iconic
how many sound people all together in
the band birds man let's start with
birds man so me on violin then we have
two keyboard players who both also sing
and then bass drums Bert's on piano
three singers and then Bert's done
Oliver plays with us as well on a couple
tunes and then and then we have two we
have a guy who does woodwinds sax flute
clarinet and then a trumpet player so
you got my 12 guys 12 yeah to get on
them what about birds or anchors organs
Anka's it's way bigger bigger back yeah
we do a lot of big band stuff and
especially now cuz we're doing the
Sinatra show so there are we pick up
horns in different cities you know we
have the the West Coast horns and then
we have the East Coast horns and but we
our lead trumpet player is always the
same so the the touring band the core
band is guitar bass drums percussion me
since piano and then our music director
John cross he does sax and clarinet he's
a woodwind guy and then we have a
trombone player and usually we travel
with two trumpet players so that's 12
and I count that right thank you but we
also add people so like sometimes we'll
have four trumpet players three
trombones
and you know extra we're talking about
22 people yeah plus we travel with
anchor we travel with a lot of crew
that's what's always this is why I've
always had respect for bands like what a
band comes and go like the whole thing
this band is great you have to leave I
always go it could kick me in the mix
out yeah hit me on the third album
people get mad at me we're not giving up
a chance because I've been down the
street before mm-hmm I respect that one
because they had done it out yeah I
respect the stones because they got 50
[ __ ] atoms
yeah and for anybody who knows when I
get out of stage I'm responsible for one
person my action they don't laugh I
sucked the bag of dicks no two ways
about it wasn't the audience not that
they're old now looking to fall asleep
it wasn't too late they weren't tired I
ate the bag of dick right when you're in
a band like that have all 22 people have
to be having a good night yep like
that's always yeah everybody the band
has to smoke the same [ __ ] no this is
the same CBDR yeah we all have to be
connected in some way and that's what I
really always take my hats off to bands
yeah I know Aerosmith you know they want
a narrow and [ __ ] went to rehab hate
each other and then made it work the
Eagles but people just have no idea what
it's like to travel what you know Guns
and Roses a year yeah Vince Neil and
Motley Crue a [ __ ] year it's you
don't come home for a [ __ ] year with
four smelly [ __ ] talking about the same
[ __ ] every [ __ ] day yeah rehearsing
eating [ __ ]
doing heroin it gets old yes ain't like
it you know I can't wait to be in a band
and get chlamydia but do it for 18
months and the record labels wanting you
that they want no music and you busy
snorting coke you know you have to five
people have to be in tune and yeah
that's why you guys have and forget
about your world yeah you know what I
used to go to the LA Phil for the Jazz
series I look
and count 40 [ __ ] up on the
stage oh yeah what do you [ __ ]
with this 20 [ __ ] doing this
all you know and you're like oh my god
that's
it's like watching synchronized swimming
yeah exactly
it's it's just a beautiful [ __ ] thing
now you see it when you're up there and
you're a part of that it's amazing
there's there's nothing that I can
really even compare it to accept that to
be when you know that your contribution
is important to creating this beautiful
piece of music you know without you it
wouldn't be the same so you feel this
sort of sense of ownership of it even
though it's not your own music you know
you feel like look I have to be the best
that I can be because the way I am is
gonna affect the person next to me so I
have whatever I'm feeling if I'm tired
if I you know I'm stressed out
whatever it is that all has to go away
you have to be like oh you know maybe
you just find out that your dog is dying
before you go onstage you have to ignore
that you can't bring that to the
audience the audience is there to have a
good time to see you know a show and
your dog could be dying and no one
should ever know you know it's and but
it's it's challenging but it's so
rewarding to me you know and then when
I'm offstage then I'm like okay
back to my dying dog yeah people would
be people to do my dishes what did you
bring me out are you broke right yeah
you I brought you that thing looks like
it's been through [ __ ] war it has I
have taped it back together oh my music
from Burt Bacharach show
yeah you mind if I read this yeah sure
so this is the UCLA set what you see
like that list yeah that was I think
last year so one two three four five but
then see where it says like record
medley one right oh it's a day nine
friends
record medley one is don't make me over
walk on by reach out for me that's right
yeah I'm Warwick - yeah that's right
this guy's in love I say a little prayer
um who sang I said a little prayer for
you forever I think it was Dion Dion
oh I think it was Dion yeah so he Burt
wrote those for Dionne Warwick Tommy he
wrote do you know the way to San Jose he
did not jump off this [ __ ] baby yeah
and then we have trains and boats to go
that was the oldest joke when I got that
way yeah everybody was oh yeah everybody
because he was working for the psychic
Senate remember I remember 97 every
[ __ ] joke had Dionne Warwick do you
know the way to San Jose but you're a
[ __ ] psychic that was like not that
he did all that writing for Dia yeah and
and he wrote the one that I find that
the youngest people because I always say
people will say oh I don't know who Burt
Bacharach is like I was talking to my
overdrive for the other day and he asked
me excited my instrument and I was like
yeah play for Burt Bacharach you know
he's like I don't know who that is nice
I was like is he do you know who that is
you know that song always something
there to remind me from the 80s
that's Burt Bacharach I didn't even know
that yeah it's bugging me there's a
movie where someone goes coming to the
stage Burt Bacharach and I can't play
for powers yeah okay yeah all right
I am now introducing mr. Burt Bacharach
and he's on the bus I couldn't I could I
really so it's distinct I was like I
know I could hurt it yeah Oh
is why I wanted you to come on I want to
educate people you you're beautiful what
you do is tremendous we're not even
gonna have a closing song I wish you
would play a little violin for us on the
way out okay
tonight I think that would be
appropriate [ __ ] Tony Bennett Tony
Bennett let's listen to a little ours
Eliza James yeah James James James yes
do you have busy because you're talking
about like people having to be in sync
but what about I'm sure you must have an
extra but have you had like a violin
break or something crazy like that huh
yes yeah the the strings definitely
break they I was in my college audition
before I decided I was going to stay in
California I auditioned for Cleveland
Institute of Music and think of me I
like the sunshine better so I get here
but I was in the middle of my audition
and the president of the university is
sitting there and you know classical
auditions are very stressful and there
are people who judge them are very very
judgy and you know I was 17 I think and
I'm in the middle of this Bach piece in
my e-string breaks right by the bridge
so close to my face flips up hits me in
the nose and my nose starts bleeding and
I'm just like go to the other string and
I try I'm like trying to play this
emajor party that I'm way up here in the
a string and it's not really working and
the president of the university was like
it's okay you can stop don't bleed on
your instrument but yeah it's I've had
I've had a we were I was out with Bert
we were in Australia and you know
traveling with instruments on airlines
is horrible and I had actually a bigger
violin case than I do now and so every
time I would get in line oh that doesn't
fit me overhead oh that doesn't I'm like
do you know how my
this is been on like I got it to
Australia somehow so clearly it fits in
some overhead not that one not it was a
different case so they it was Qantas and
they were just you know sometimes flight
attendants are having a really bad day
and they just want to make it your bad
day and the guy he wasn't you can't
bring that on you have too many things I
had a suitcase I'd violin that's it and
so he makes me check the suitcase and
then takes my laptop they won't let me
hold the laptop in my lap while we take
off and they're like you have to put
that in the overhead so my laptops
bouncing around in the overhead I'm like
great this is starting off well and I
said don't put it on my violin case what
do they do they put it right on top my
violin case it bounces during takeoff
snaps my bridge in half and I had a
panic attack like when I got to the
hotel I opened the case and the bridge
was snapped in half it could have
cracked the entire instrument and ruined
the instrument my my instrument his name
is Jacques and he's almost a hundred
years old
Wow and you know you can't it's
irreplaceable you can't just make
another one and so that was pretty awful
I would say that's the worst that's the
worst disaster I've ever had I have
Jacques over here and I have I'm
endorsed by a company called NS design
and they make these really cool electric
violins my string quartet quartet four
or five were all endorsed by them
that's why sale yesterday yeah yeah
that's film John video Twitter page yeah
yeah we have a lot of fun that was great
we're doing we're doing another one
we're doing a music right yeah we just
got a former violist lila she moved to
Nashville to work on some projects there
so we got a new violist her name's Jana
chow and she's amazing and we're doing a
tribute to Paul Anka she she wrote an
arrangement and we're gonna have a
backyard party and shoot a music thing
some will seem to be off-color here why
did I see so many Asian violinist for so
long and then I saw your beautiful face
well I think that it comes with Asians
yeah
it's huge and and I think that a lot of
Asian cultures are very they're very
disciplined you know there's a there's a
there's a method called the Suzuki
method which I learned when I was a kid
it's for actually your daughter may may
have I don't know do you know what she
was born yeah because that's something
that Suzuki does start yeah did she play
Bette Denon and in it yes yes yes yes
Mississippi hot dog yeah that we called
it but yeah that's Suzuki method and
that was started during World War two by
a guy dr. Suzuki
in Japan and he was the first person to
make child sized violins because up
until then you couldn't really play
music as a child that violin didn't
there wasn't really smaller ones so he
started a factory that would produce
child sized violins and so it came from
Japan and then just spread but it was
funny I remember as a kid I was in a
group class and all of the uh all of the
students were Asian except for me and so
I went home and I asked my mom like a
five year old like mommy
um can I change my last name to Chang
and she was like what and I said yeah I
think I think it'll make me play better
my last name is Chang I think I'll play
violin better so you know it's I think
it's also it's a the parents are super
involved with their kids they come to
all the lessons it's it's a method and
it's a way of learning instruments and
it's not just violin it's violin cello
viola they have a Suzuki piano but it's
not as it's not done as often there's
harp I think there's even guitar
flute but it's a really good method for
kids to learn what's them between the
violin the violin a viola is like you
know in a choir
you have the soprano alto tenor bass
like Sopranos are the highest voice so
that's the violin voice the alto voice
is the viola voice and then you have the
tenor which is cello and then bass which
is upper base so it's it's the range of
the instrument and the instrument itself
is bigger so it's it has that have lower
strings so the body of it has to be
bigger in order to make the vibrations I
was having a good time - you brought up
this music because I always wish I
learned how to read music this is my
first passion yeah and because I was a
loser I quit and I became a comic
because on my guitar if I with my drug
problem and looking at this music makes
me so [ __ ] depressed right now I want
to shoot myself and buy a guitar do it
but I can't because I have an addictive
personality I would if I start playing a
guitar I'd be in this office from 9:00
in the morning till 12:00 listened to
Pink Floyd dogs learning how to do the
guitar solo or the dogs and I would
leave my wife my kid because I know I
have Yashin for it so yeah it sounds
like my uh my cousins in Cuba there's a
national band of Cuba oh wow my cousins
Emmy Alfonso and all bad like oh so you
know this was my er this is what's in my
DNA
yeah I just was too much of a [ __ ] to
go for it I knew that you know I started
with the bass and I got it and then I
figured I'd get into the guitar later on
and just as I was getting close I have a
drug problem like oh you know what I'm
not that stupid if I paid 300 for a
guitar
every time my fiend I'm gonna pawn the
guitar this guitars will be in another
pawn shops so I never really had a
chance to really get involved and so you
go the slower at you become a comedian
see this
you don't even need a microphone or you
need is a wall and three idiots to
listen you know so well you could always
learn violin and with your daughter talk
to her we'll talk to it tonight and see
where we stand with the violin or the
other yeah cuz you know what I find that
whip kids like the most important job
that you have as a teacher is to inspire
that's what you that's what you're there
for your in your telling you're teaching
them things you know this is how you
play this but the most important thing
is to inspire them to then go and teach
themselves you know you oh if I always
think that if the student is better than
the teacher then you've succeeded so you
know it could be and and the Suzuki
method when I used to teach a lot before
I started touring and I would have
parents up to a certain age like if
there were 13 years old they didn't have
to have a parent in the lesson but you
know it's really helpful parents writing
down notes interacting sometimes some
parents would they Brent a violin and
they'd learn alongside their kid and
when the kid sees mom or dad's doing it
oh it's cool now you know now I'm not
just alone in a room by myself trying to
learn music I you know when I was little
I used to my dad would come home from
work and I put on concerts we'd have
dinner concerts so I think you know if
you involve the whole the whole process
of learning if your kid sees that you're
doing it it's gonna be it's gonna
inspire them to so a word of
encouragement I can't see myself doing
Tchaikovsky right now just [ __ ]
whatever doesn't that I love it yeah I
love the power of it's like I've always
loved the power I just want to see some
time to see something oh what the Radio
City Christmas shop Oh
my dad came up and I was like Jesus
Christ the [ __ ] energy that's what
I'm gonna ask
real quick for comedy when you're in a
theater after it's a bigot when you're
in a comedy club it's it's a game of
ping-pong would you run a theater the
the energy flow and a theater for a
comedian
is a it's to senior citizens playing
tennis yeah I hit the ball the ball
bounces the energy goes up onto the
rafters they received the energy and the
life that comes back at you so it's a
ping pong of energy yeah ain't no small
room it's a ping pong yeah in 1200 seat
theater it's tennis how does it feel as
a musician in a big is that the same
energy you're receiving it is in a way
yeah it's you especially when you can't
see the audience I love that yeah you
don't like seeing them either I it
depends um it's kind of funny if when
I'm out with ANCA or Burt and I know
that I have family or friends in the
audience I like to see them because I'm
excited I mean but if I'm playing you
know if I'm doing like a classical solo
and I have any amount of nervousness I
don't even want what to know that you're
there you know if I know you I don't
want to know that you're there don't
make me you know it's easier for me to
play for strangers but when I can see we
can usually see like the first couple
rows right I don't mind if I mean I
gotta see and now something that's
really gets kind of frustrating is and I
don't mind it anchor doesn't mind when
people take video or photos during the
show but sometimes I don't know if
you've had this happen what is with the
iPads why are why are you bringing your
giant freaking computer size iPad to egg
show on full brightness and holding it
up over your head
videoing I don't understand it because I
can see I can see from the stage that
the person in the third to last row of
this 1200 seat theater is facetiming
someone I can see the face of the person
alive because the way that it's lit up
and so cheaply they look at me I'm to
the point that that that is distracting
the point where there's a bunch of
comedians sort of putting phones away
because they say phones a distracting
into the thaad if my ring and it's
certain comics to be cool than otherwise
had jumped on the bandwagon yeah I'm
thinking of doing it because I'm sick
and tired of going online every night
and seeing you know the stolen - playing
Thursday wake up Friday morning there's
a thousand videos of the stones
yeah why why aren't you living your
[ __ ] life yeah
why do you have a camera huh taping a
[ __ ] concert
why aren't you enjoying it why aren't
you focusing on the bass player for five
minutes
yeah I'm focusing on Charlie watt then
focusing on Keith Richards doing and
then focus and then focusing on the
audience yeah that's all I see if these
[ __ ] places yeah I want them to ban
the phones so people can enjoy the
experience
yeah the [ __ ] phone away enjoy the
experience or they put it up like
writers like [ __ ] what happened to
the seventies when you burn your finger
you think I would do I look like the tie
with 100 concerts I've never taken a
[ __ ] liner out of my hands
that's for pure [ __ ] have a good
time that drives me [ __ ] crazy drives
me to the last war if you pay three
hours to go to the stones yeah well most
of course he Burt Bacharach or [ __ ]
Paul Anka or Liza James do me a favor
keep your phone in your pocket to
vibrate I know you got family yeah yeah
no you have a sick dad but besides that
guess what I don't want to see
should he take them can you show me that
you were cheap enough to sit all the way
up in the Martian disease and then the
[ __ ] fall away there's so many people
last we put up Mick Jagger from Newark
you're [ __ ] embarrassing yeah you're
a [ __ ] embarrassment put the [ __ ]
phone away and enjoy the event yeah for
what it is that's why I don't want
phones anymore
because people are not and you let me
take a picture put the [ __ ] thing
down yeah I think Anka does a really
good job of that like I think that
sometimes people get carried away but he
he has a whole part of the show where he
runs through the audience and he'll take
pictures with people you know and then
that part of the show is done you know
and now you can focus on music but they
get there they get their photo with him
they get their little video you know and
he's he is super cool about it but it's
the iPad thing really kind of irks me
you know it's like a phone it's one
thing when you have like a giant scream
it's like why would you do that anyway
who's carrying around a giant iPad
screen to a concert so I'm gonna read
this last ad do you mind taking out the
vial yeah that was not the show a little
I can so where can they find you I
wanted to follow you on twitter because
it's not following Eliza James on
Twitter you're [ __ ] up oh it's a
learning experience one night she's in
Connecticut one night she's jumping up
and down with Pollock she's everywhere
you have love for comedy like your
friends I do I've been friends with
Donna I've been friends with Donnell for
like over ten years along the line
you're a comedy family yeah yeah I love
comedy I you know comedy for me is a way
to unwind after a show because I can't
if I watch something that has music in
it my brain doesn't shut off so for me
relaxation is comedy and I laugh and I
go to sleep and I'm happy
and you came to the comments though
wouldn't that I gave you one quick hug
and I was out yeah I gotta go and I
gotta get arrived because the experience
I get from just following you on Twitter
oh my [ __ ] about bitching about
Airlines put a picture of months ago
with you and Bert bat rack yeah and I
was like that is so [ __ ] I love him I
really I know I could tell I can tell
that you have been I hate saying this
word cuz you sound so cliche with all
these other [ __ ] jerk clothes but God
is watched over you you owe him big
because you're getting an education that
most people [ __ ] you can't pay for
that right if you paid to go to Yale you
can't get the education you're getting
you know that is and that's what most
people don't understand in life that you
appreciate the education you get you're
the world's best that as good as it gets
most [ __ ] guys so yeah you're very
lucky
anytime you're in town I know you live
close by yeah you always welcome to stop
by and [ __ ] play the violin let me
read all right I'm gonna get my violin
out yeah do this [ __ ] alright like I
said in the beginning of this show this
show is brought to you by honest as
usual my favorite the supplements are
tremendous they just sent me a
tremendous box I made a beautiful
chocolate shake this morning with ice
cubes and some water oh tremendous the
cocoa whatever the [ __ ] it is I love on
it I love the alpha brain I love the
shroom tech immune the shroom tech
support and listen some little snacks
forget about it from now on you just get
those coconut I'm in chocolate 7 grams
of protein 3 grams of carbs and 1 gram
of sugar or something [ __ ] tremendous
go to town on it calm right now look at
the great selection they have I'm
supplements I can help you out with the
kettlebells the club bats but the
supplements I'll get you 10% off
across-the-board going on it right now
then check out press in church CH you
are CH and get 10% off and also remember
listen these days a lot of jobs offer
pretty nice perks but they offer your
insurance
it's kind of half Moluccan go to policy
genius.com right now in minutes you can
compare coach quotes from top insurers
you get the right amount of coverage at
the best possible price and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they could also help you write to
find the right home insurance auto
insurance and disability insurance you
guys you know how hard it is to get
insurance you know how much of a pain es
it's over Uncle Joe is here to sift
right through that go to policy
genius.com right now policy genius.com
right now and find out how to supplement
your workplace life insurance and better
protect your family listen I watched a
meal last night it's family first work
second remember head to policy
genius.com today and find out how to
supplement that life insurance
Plus get your life insurance today at
policy genius calm and tell them uncle
Joey sent you so I want to give a shout
out to paly policy genius.com
and on it don't forget there's only one
ticket left for the Icehouse the 31st
February 13th and Dallas and no February
13th when I keep saying February 13th or
September 13th of dollars and September
27th at Chicago field I'll see you
[ __ ] there have a great weekend
I want to thank the Liza James kickin
Eliza kick this [ __ ] meal
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] beautiful I love you guys
she made me tear up that's real talent
I'm just a fat [ __ ] felling that
cracks jokes that's real [ __ ] town
I'll see you guys Monday morning ready
to rock have a great weekend